les soldats allemands prennent place
face au franc tireur défenseurs de la
ville de châteaudun contre l'envahisseur
nous sommes en octobre 1870 le combat
héroïque des dunois connaît un
retentissement outre-atlantique à
chicago sur la côte est en irlande the
times à londres en a parlé en parlant
des faits héroïques des dunes on a aidé
d'une oie des francs-tireurs par rapport
à cette bataille de dix ans en dix où il
y avait un dunois milles de son dunois
et francs tireurs pour 12000 prussiens 1
pour 10 6
les soldats qui vous convoitiez à
château et qui ont défendu la ville
étaient principalement des habitants de
la ville certains qui sont et rapidement
miss quand l'ennemi crucien assez pointé
aux portes de la france ce sont surtout
des paysans qui ont pris l'uniforme ou
qui ont pris les armes tout court des
des petits commerçants des artisans il
ya beaucoup de maîtres d'école qui sont
senti investi d'une d'une volonté de
défendre la république aussi la ville de
châteaudun rend hommage à ces
combattants qui firent le sacrifice de
leur vie et aux femmes nombreuses à
l'arrière du front l'une d'entre elles
est entré à jamais dans les livres
d'histoire madame jarre tout en fait
c'était une femme d'un franc-tireur
d'une personne qui sont engagés dans les
francs tireurs et à la voulu le suivre
pour prendre part au combat donc elle
s'est engagée dans les francs tireurs
entendent cantinière et suit en fait à
la bataille de châteaudun elle a été
médaillée de la légion d'honneur pascal
était très très courageuse pendant cette
bataille elle à les ravitailler sa
troupe bas notamment en munitions mais
aussi elle soignait les blessés qui
étaient sur le front voilà l'offre et
les premiers pansements et elle
distribuait un petit peu d'euros montant
réconfort qui ne suffit pas à remporter
la bataille les châteaudun et gagna une
reconnaissance éternelle elle est l'une
des rares villes françaises à être
décoré de la croix de la légion
d'honneur